[Music]
hey everyone
welcome to another installment of harry
potter theory
in this video we're going to be
discussing the order of the phoenix the
death eaters
and the battle of the department of
mysteries this battle was one of the
most important in the series
and one of the most action-packed on
screen it was also quite tragic
as it highlighted sirius black's last
moments first being struck by a curse
from bellatrix and then falling into the
vale
the department of mysteries is on level
9 of the ministry of magic
and this department is responsible for
studying the mysteries of the wizarding
world
mysteries associated with love space
thought
time and death among other things but
perhaps most importantly
within the walls of the department of
mysteries lies the hall of prophecy
they were there they had found the place
high as a church and full of nothing but
towering shelves
covered in small dusty glass orbs they
glimmered dully in a light issuing from
wall candle brackets set at intervals
along the shelves
like those in the circular room behind
them their flames were burning blue
the room was very cold and it was in the
wall of prophecy that harry potter
among others were suddenly faced with a
horde of death eaters
and the battle that would ensue would be
the first major conflict of the second
wizarding war
harry was lord to the department of
mysteries by voldemort who sought to
come into the possession of a prophecy
that foretold his defeat at the hands of
potter when harry ron hemani neville
jinny and luna showed up death users
were waiting for them and the fight
began
the order of the phoenix show up later
to help fight alongside dumbledore's
army
but one thing that i've always found
peculiar is six hogwarts students were
able to fight off some of the dark
lord's
most powerful servants they were
outnumbered and honestly
if you factor in the death eaters like
bellatrix and dolorhov were there
outclassed harry put his ear close to
the door to listen
and heard lucius malfoy raw leave not
leave him
i say the dark lord will not care for
not injuries as much as losing that
prophecy
jugson come back here we need to
organize we'll split into pairs and
search
and don't forget be gentle with potter
until we've got the prophecy
you can kill the others if necessary
bellatrix adolphus you take the left
crab rabbiston go right jugson dolorhov
the door straight ahead mcnair and avery
through here
rookwood over there malsaba come with me
here we see
very clearly that the death eaters were
ordered to kill everyone
except for harry but from what we can
extract from the text the death eaters
were very clearly
using ineffective non-fatal and in some
cases
silly spells and what about ron said
harry fearfully
as ron continued to giggle still hanging
off the front of harry's robes
i don't know what they hit him with said
luna sadly but he's gone a bit funny
i could hardly get him along at all also
its owner was laying on his side
bleeding from the head and his attacker
was now bearing down upon harry and
neville
dolorhov his long pale face twisted with
glee tarant allegra he shouted his wand
pointing at neville
whose legs went immediately into a kind
of frenzy tap dance unbouncing him and
causing him to fall to the floor again
now potter so this begs the question why
are they holding back
why are they using taran telegraph and
not avada kadavra
crucio aren't the death eaters stone
cold killers
i think there may be a few reasons for
this first of all
they were just kids and i honestly think
that the death eaters
knowing that they both outnumbered and
how class the kids held back a bit
because they were toying with them sure
the members of dumbledore's army proved
themselves as valiant fighters
but realistically how could they expect
to compete with vast numbers of superior
witches and wizards
i think that they were casting spells
like tarrant allegra for a bit of a
laugh
to have some fun at that point in time
they didn't expect the order of the
phoenix to show up
and would have likely felt quite
comfortable additionally death eaters
are quite sadistic
so it's highly likely they would want to
humiliate them before finishing them off
as i mentioned before this was the first
major conflict the second wizarding war
and this would have been the first
opportunity they had in a while to do
what they love
battle my next theory is that the death
eaters used whatever spell was quick and
accessible for them in the heat of
battle
channeling a spell like avada kadavra in
the heat of the moment
might not always be the best option it
was a fast-paced fire fight that
required split-second decisions
and they may have just cast whatever
felt most natural for them sure
town allegra is silly but it does serve
a purpose
even if it's just a precursor to a spell
that would serve as the finisher
we see this with harry who time and time
again resorts to expelliarmus which is
certainly not the most powerful spell in
his arsenal
however it clearly worked for him time
and time again as with it he was able to
escape from the stickiest of situations
i honestly think that a lot of it comes
down to convenience and comfort
use the spells that are guaranteed to
work what do you guys think
why was an outnumbered dumbledore's army
able to fend off a plethora of death
eaters
let us know down in the comment section
below until next time
your wizard harry
you